[Music]
foreign
first thing a very good morning to you
wherever you're watching us around the
world we start with breaking news on the
economy new figures from the office for
National statistics show inflation has
unexpectedly gone up to 10.4 percent in
February the Consumer Price Index or CPI
was expected to come down from January's
10.1 oh my goodness me how bad news is
that for the government Gulf Richard is
here hi good morning tell us more yeah
it's it's a bit worrying for policy
makers economists were expecting
inflation to come down to 9.9 but we've
had this surprise leap in inflation to
10.4 now this has just dropped so we
don't know exactly what's caused it but
some of the early signs suggest that
it's food inflation and restaurants and
cafes that have been driving this food
inflation 18 I'm being told yeah yeah
exactly well that that wouldn't be a
surprise it was around 16 uh the
previous month
um and crucially for the bank of England
this is way above where it was penciling
in inflation to be around this time of
the year which means that there's more
pressure now on the bank to raise
interest rates when policy makers meet
next week and of course there are other
worrying signs in the economy as well
the labor market although it's starting
to soften wages are still Rising pretty
robustly
um even though they are lagging behind
inflation and if wages rise too quickly
that could put pressure on
um on prices because businesses have to
raise their prices in order to protect
their profits and of course inflation is
also
five times the bank of England's uh two
percent Target and although in recent
weeks and days Market expectations of
where interest rates might end up have
come down this suggests that they might
have to ratchet them back up again just
very quickly what does this mean for our
mortgages well it means that as I just
said that interest rates might have to
stay longer for higher which means will
they go higher still they could do so in
recent weeks and in recent days markets
have expected their interest rates might
actually
uh Peak at a much lower level than we
were expecting and the bank of England
might not actually even raise interest
rates when it meets next week but all of
this suggests that you may have to okay
for now thanks so much indeed thank you
in other news Boris Johnson will face
MPS later for a grilling that could
decide his political future he's
fighting for his political life today
former prime minister has admitted
misleading the House of Commons over
dining Street parties in lockdown but
insists it wasn't intentional it is
unable to convince the Privileges
committee Mr Johnson could be suspended
from Parliament and even ultimately face
a by-election Liz hasmore
a confidently evidence will clear Mr
Johnson no more walking away for the
former prime minister who today must
finally face MPS and four hours of
questions over whether he recklessly
misled Parliament over partygate
back in December 2020 as evidence that
illegal Gatherings had taken place in
Downing Street mounted Boris Johnson
repeatedly told the House of Commons no
rules had been broken
all guidance was followed completely
during number 10. I have been repeatedly
assured since these allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that and that no covid rules were
broken the guidance was followed and the
rules were followed at all times
we now know that wasn't true it's up to
the Privileges committee to decide
whether he knew that at the time
yesterday they published his defense a
50-page dossier drawn up by lawyers
arguing that during his rule-breaking
birthday party no cake was even eaten
that he couldn't have known about the
other parties because he was working day
and night blaming his aides saying no
one advised me after any of these events
that they were against the rules
people do mislead the house by accident
you know that you you must speak if you
say you have to understand uh every
single nuance and you're going to be
able to account based on new facts
received and punished on that basis
ministers will simply come to the
dispatch box and say I can't possibly
comment we're going to have to have an
inquiry I can't talk about that
his allies say it's a labor stitch up
because the committee chair is party
Grandy Harriet Harman despite
conservative MPS being in the majority
I think he's saying it to try to weasel
out of it frankly this is a man who has
never taken responsibility for anything
in his life and doesn't intend to start
now
the committee's verdict could lead to a
suspension and even a by-election in his
Uxbridge and ruislip constituency
not just his political future the
current prime ministers is also on the
line as the Scandal that has haunted the
conservative party raise its head once
again this baits Sky News Westminster
underlining those figures before we move
on to more about Boris Johnson food
inflation up 18 almost a fifth impact
it's having on you do let us know your
thoughts you can tweet me directly at
Cape early also the inflation figure
staying in double figures so many
thought that it would come down to about
9.8 9.9 percent that's not happening a
few Jitters in Downing streets this
morning not least because of the
privilege is committee they're going to
publish new material ahead of that
hearing later on this morning uh later
on this that's when they're going to
print it but the publisher I should say
but the actual hearing there we go we're
getting there two o'clock this afternoon
so fresh information this morning the
hearing at 2PM this afternoon it's going
to last about four hours or so Boris
Johnson fighting for his political life
and if that wasn't enough for Rishi
tsunaki's New brexit Deal for Northern
Ireland that goes to a Commons vote
today and the Prime Minister faces
Rebellion on his own benches and not
long ago Boris Johnson said that he will
be voting against Rishi sunax wins the
framework in a statement the former PM
said the proposals were unacceptable
adding that the best course of action is
to proceed with Northern Ireland
protocol bill
you're a skeptic Tory MPS have hinted
they'll vote against the deal as well
they're critical of the so-called
Stormont break which is intended to
provide a veto on the imposition of new
EU regulations in Northern Ireland the
Prime Minister can rely on the support
of Labor and other parties in getting
the deal passed
some of today's other headlines for you
on the program this morning a man has
been arrested on suspicion of attempted
murder after another man was set on fire
while walking home from a mosque in
Birmingham on Monday evening
counterterra police are now
investigating the incident along with
the West Midlands police warning that
viewers may find the following images
which include the moment the man was set
on fire distressing
images were captured on CCTV and they
show the victim being stopped in the
street by another man who points his
finger at him the attacker then appears
to push the man to prevent him from
getting past moments later the pair move
up the road you can see them to the left
of the screen there they are and the
victim
is then set on fire
a man has been arrested
at least 13 people are known to have
died in Pakistan and Afghanistan after a
six and a half magnitude earthquake
shook both countries the Tremor was also
felt in parts of India and several
Central Nations across Central Asia
uganda's Parliament has overwhelmingly
approved a new bill further targeting
the lgbtq plus community that already
faces legal discrimination and mob
violence it allows jail terms of up to
10 years for same-sex relations and
potentially the death penalty for what's
described as aggravated homosexuality
when it involves people under 18.
Gwyneth Paltrow has appeared in court
over a skiing accident that happened
back in 2016. Terry Sanderson says she
crashed into him on the slopes and left
him permanently injured and is soon for
three hundred thousand dollars the actor
argues that it was Mr Sanderson who
caused the accident and is character
suing for a dollar
the government has reportedly scrapped
plans to bring forward a rise in the
state pension age the age which is
currently 66 was due to rise to 68 after
2044 reports had suggested that
ministers plan to bring the increase
forward to the end of the next decade
which would affect people who are now in
their early 50s according to the Ft the
government has decided to delay a
decision because of falling life
expectancy and concerns about anger
among aged voters
department for work and pension
spokesperson said the government is
required by law to regularly review the
state pension age and the next review
will be published by the 7th of May the
pension age is still due to rise to 67
by the end of 2028.
and we want to know what you think about
that story today how do you feel about
working until the age of 68 the
chancellor says the pension age will
have to rise but ministers could try to
push it until after the next election
you can show your thoughts with me on
Twitter at K Burley and I'll read them
out on the Telly for the whole world to
listen to so how do you feel about
potentially working till the age of 68.
remember that the French had been
rioting because it's increasing age from
potential age from 62 to 64 Brits could
work to the age of 68 potentially by the
mid-2040s thoughts on that if you
wouldn't mind please at Cape early
in other news research has found women
May face an increased breast cancer risk
from taking any kind of hormonal
contraceptive the Oxford University
scientist behind the study were Keen
however to emphasize that their findings
should be taken in the context of the
drugs well-established benefits Alice is
Withers hi Alice good morning to you
tell us a bit more so how worried should
women on the taking contraceptive pills
this morning or the other forms of
contraception as well be this morning
they shouldn't be worried I think that's
really really important to stress we
know that women who take the combined
pills that's a progesterone and estrogen
we know that those women have always had
a slight increase of getting breast
cancer but this has been one of the few
studies to look at those who aren't
taking the progesterone only pill so
also known as the mini pill that's
increased in popularity a lot over the
last few years and that's why
researchers from Oxford University
that's why they want to examine what
those increased risks would be so they
looked at around 30 000 patient records
and they found for those who who take
progesterone only pills over five years
that increase their chances over the
next 15 years of getting breast cancer
by around 20 or 30 percent now that
sounds a lot but actual in actual real
terms of an actual increase in cases if
we looked at a hundred thousand women
who took this progesterone only peel
pill it would mean you'd only have an
extra eight cases of breast cancer if
they took the pill into their late 20s
and for those who take the pill into
their late 30s it's only an extra 264
women so the numbers are very small and
also crucially your chances of having
breast cancer in your 20s and 30s are
quite low and you're more likely to take
the pill than someone in your late 30s
and 40s who have an increased risk of
breast cancer okay as far as the coil is
concerned that's caught up in this as
well isn't it yes as well I mean across
the board it's important to stress that
all women depending on what uh
contraceptive they take there is an
increased chance of them having breast
cancer but it's important to stress as
well their chances of having ovarian
cancer and womb cancer are decreased
significantly by taking any form of
contraception as well so it's all about
weighing up the pros and cons but if
anyone is watching this and they've got
concerns talk to your GP talk to your
family planning about it I had risks
having getting pregnant as well under
whatever circumstances thanks very much
indeed Alice thank you now is the Met
police digest baroness cases damning
review Sky News has uncovered bullying
and misogyny at another Force we've
spoken to a serving officer at Humber
side police who say she was left
traumatized by sexual abuse from a
fellow Officer Jason has more for us he
was here yesterday hi Jason good morning
tell us more so obviously yesterday was
a Day of Reckoning for the Metropolitan
Police being told that they were
institutionally misogynistic racist and
homophobic and they you know we've been
told this is going to take a long time
for this all to be resolved within the
met but at the same time I was talking
to baroness Casey and I asked her do you
know do you think there should be a
review similar to yours in other police
forces and she said she thought there
there should be and the reason I asked
the question is because we had seen um
in humbicide police
um testimony from women suggesting that
there is misogyny there and actually the
parallels between Louise Casey's review
and some of the examples in There Were
Striking so as you say we have the story
of a police officer who is still serving
within the force and a an alleged rape
victim who manages to get a subject
access request which is to find out all
the information about herself and what's
been said about her by the police and
you can see it in this report
for a while seeing a police officer in
uniform I'd have like flashbacks
if something happened to me again I
don't think I'd ever report it
this is a serving police officer so
traumatized by the abuse from a fellow
officer she's questioning her own Force
humbicide constabulary was rated
outstanding by the police inspectorate
but Sally says when it became known that
she'd reported a fellow officer for
sexual violence her colleagues rallied
around him
I was ostracized given cold shoulder so
I had to be stared at or given dirty
looks
they were like school yeah bullies
after the misconduct hearing so after he
lost his job I lost count of the amount
of offices that came up to me and said I
was always being like that really yeah
and he'd been in the job a really long
time
and I thought well why have they not
said anything then yeah he basically had
the same nicknames as those monsters in
the mat
Wayne cousins was nicknamed the rapist
by fellow officers before he murdered
Sarah everard David Carrick a serial
rapist was in the same unit now the
Casey review has found the Met police's
institutionally sexist but does it go
wider should there be a Louise Casey
type review into every other police
force I actually think the answer to
that is yes because I think that what we
have found there are some things there
light vetting like sort of the cultural
issues particularly around racing around
women I think that they are National
issues Anna alleged as a teenager that
she was being raped by a gang of men in
Hull she used what's called a subject
access request to get homicide police
records on herself she found these types
of comments made by officers if the
reports are genuine we have a very
vulnerable victim who keeps putting
herself in danger this is a very regular
occurrence the female herself is making
lifestyle choices of her own this victim
doesn't come across as the best type of
witness victim that I've seen I was
really vulnerable I was on a protection
plan it said how I was getting strangled
I was being sexually assaulted I was
high risk but there's no wonder the case
was never brought to court because
before it's even got there they've
completely undermined it in one extract
police seem to accept the alleged
attackers story that there is bruising
on Anna because she liked violent sex
after a review Anna's investigation was
reopened and for that reason humberside
police say they can't comment further
but deputy chief Constable Paul Anderson
said child sexual abuse and exploitation
is a deplorable and condemnable crime
and we're determined to bring offenders
to Justice and hold them accountable for
their actions with regard to Sally the
force says misogynistic Behavior will
not be tolerated adding there is an
existing robust process in place anyone
who exhibits any form of misogynistic or
discriminatory Behavior will be held
accountable for their actions Sally says
she's still proud to be a police officer
but is speaking out because she wants
change Louie's Casey's report suggests
that will only come if all officers have
the same attitude
so Louise Casey's review which has
rocked the Met is something she believes
should be extended out to other police
forces and from the testimony of just
those two women it does seem as if this
is a problem that extends far beyond
just one police force okay for now
thanks very much indeed Jason thank you
Jason with us throughout the morning on
the breakfast show here on Sky News
hopefully you will be too seven police
officers among 10 people indicted in the
U.S state of Virginia over the death of
a mentally ill man in custody over
otieno died when he was being
transported from the Henrico County Jail
to a state-run psychiatric facility
a warning that the following video shows
officers and health workers piling on
top of Mr otieno before his death
the 28 year old was handcuffed and in
leg irons when he was led to a chair in
the admission room the deputies appear
to lose their grip on Mr otieno and he's
seen falling to the floor
at least nine people held Mr etiano down
and the footage shows he was restrained
for a total of 11 minutes
in other news Russia's President
Vladimir Putin has said that Moscow will
be forced to react if the UK sends
depleted uranium tank shells to Ukraine
the Russian leader made his comments
during the visit to Moscow by Chinese
leader Xi Jinping
there came in response to a
parliamentary answer from defense
minister Annabelle Goldie that the UK
would Supply Ukraine with armor-piercing
rounds which contained depleted uranium
for use with its Challenger 2 tanks
[Applause]
it seems that the West really decided to
fight with Russia to the last Ukrainian
not in words but Deeds but in this
regard I'd like to note that if this
happens and Russia will be forced to
react accordingly given that the West is
already starting to use weapons with a
nuclear component
well the ministry of Defense has
dismissed that warning saying in a
statement that the British army has used
depleted uranium in its armor-piercing
shells for decades it's a standard
component and it has nothing to do with
nuclear weapons or capabilities Russia
knows this but is deliberately trying to
misinform
China's president XI is visiting Russia
as you know for the first time since the
invasion of Ukraine day three helenan
stunning by for us um how's it gone
Helena good morning
good morning I think both leaders would
feel from their perspectives it's gone
reasonably well president XI is on his
way home now in terms of concrete
outcomes if you like we know that a
number of bilateral deals were signed
between the two to sort of further deep
and already pretty uh deep in existing
trade ties but the one thing that a lot
of people really had their eyes on on
this Summit was whether there would be
any form of proposal or deal suggestion
maybe even ceasefire proposal as
pertains to that all-important war in
Ukraine and on that there hasn't really
been anything particularly concrete on
that war in Ukraine president XI said
that the negotiations on that were
friendly Frank and open perhaps just a
smidge of a hint there that there are
still things over which the two leaders
don't see eye to eye on and Putin for
his part uh said that he took very
seriously uh president xi's what he
calls a peace proposal that he put
forward and that it could be the basis
for further movement but look I think
the real messages out of this state
Summit were this the those two Nations
wanted to show the world that they are
very close very United you could see
that in all the Pomp and ceremony all
the closeness all the gestures it was
very very clear but also crucially this
it is President XI who has the upper
hand in this relationship no doubt about
that Russia needs China and China of
course has its own geopolitical
interests in staying close to Russia it
says it wants to be Peacemaker but
remember that Russia not losing and
being defeated by the Western Ukraine is
important to China's geopolitical
positioning as well okay helenan thank
you
back home politics at home Boris Johnson
facing her bruising cross-examination by
MPS at party Gates this afternoon before
that starts at 2PM let's speak to a
conservative MP Peter bone a
long-standing defender of the former PM
throughout party gate where there's no
hi good morning good morning always
great to see you thanks for joining us
on the program is he fighting for his
political life today not really I mean
what it is is a part of the process of
the Privileges committee he will present
he's already presented his evidence
which is pretty strong in his favor and
he'll answer the question for quite a
considerable amount of time today which
I'm sure everyone will be interested in
then the committee will go away mull
over these things and reach a decision
if the committee decides that he should
be suspended and he's suspended for 10
days or more he could face a by-election
well that's not quite right the
committee can only recommend to
Parliament than the whole of the House
of Commons votes and whatever that was
my shorthand but that's what I did and I
mean I don't think for one moment
they're going to reach that decision
because if you look at objectively to
say that Boris Johnson known you lied to
Parliament
well no misled light is the same thing
isn't it it's just there's no evidence
of it I mean haven't they had thousands
and thousands of WhatsApp messages and
they've been going on for this inquiry
for 10 months and found nothing that's
not quite what the part the committee is
saying they've released their
preliminary findings ahead of Mr Johnson
appearing before them as you know and it
would suggest that they don't think that
that's the case and he very much has a
case to answer well I don't I don't
think they've reached a conclusion uh
I'm sure they haven't received yeah well
I'm very pedantic this morning if you
had three did wait well you know getting
up early and the excitement of coming on
your program I did have my breakfast
before coming I'm glad to hear it I I'm
sure that Boris Johnson will need a good
breakfast before he gets him he's
probably asleep for us at the moment as
well but you know he they do think he
has a case to answer which is why he's
up in front of us well this is this is
the primary face here thing about well
it might be a case so you look at
there's an inquiry and it's sort of
based on the Sue gray investigation we
now know that Sue gray is what going to
be Chief of Staff to Kirsten and they
were having discussions while the while
the investigation was going no they
weren't they were having him now who's
been pedant have you had yours I don't
like Shredded Wheat but if I did I would
have well actually nor do I um yeah no
she was having discussions with them in
during the committee investigation not
during her actual investigation I'm glad
you corrected me not at all so you
wouldn't you you will I mean if they are
calling Witnesses presumably Sue gray
would be called and she is now
um
very closely involved with the leader of
labor party which must I mean I don't
think in a court of law that would be
allowed be clearly a conflict of
interest but so many of your colleagues
sat there over the previous months
during the investigation saying we must
wait for the sugary inquiry because she
is a very independent civil servant and
we didn't know at that time well I I've
said it as I said in the House of
Commons I think the fact that the senior
civil servants has gone straight from
that role to being a senior advisors
leader of labor party throws a coats and
horses through our civil service be
careful because of course you're not
protected by parliamentary privileges
out there what are you suggesting are
you suggesting that she is biased
towards the labor party and so she came
up with those conclusions no what I'm
saying and I said in the House of
Commons you know we have this tradition
of the Civil Service being there to
advise people of any political
persuasion and they don't then go and
join
um a political party
um and that's what is strange and it
breaks with the tradition and it's it's
more like we moving towards the American
system where you appoint people who
believe in what you do and then when you
leave you change them it's a big
question for the Civil Service what did
what was going through Boris Johnson's
mind then when he was eating cake on his
birthday and was raising a glass of wine
in photographs that we've seen and was
aware of at least 14 events that were
taking part in dining Street and was
also fined by the Metropolitan Police
well if you need I mean the only event
that um he got fined for was the the
cake in the when he was having a work
meeting and somebody turned up as a
surprise piece of cake which by the way
was published at the time in fact it was
in the Times newspaper nobody thought
anything of it it wasn't pre-planned by
Boris and all so none of the other so
why did he accept that he'd broken the
rules well because the police found him
guilty of doing it
but that was that was the only event
wasn't he didn't have to accept that
fine did he he could have challenged it
in court he chose not to well I'm sure
he could have done but the the point is
you're saying he was at all lots of
these different uh what you'd call
parties but he wasn't no no I was saying
he was at 14 separate events and that's
what he will have to be answering what
did he think they were their work
meetings yeah and you do you often have
wine at work meetings I I don't drink
okay well that's that's do you I mean I
look pleasure I mean when Scott has a
business meeting do you occasionally
have a drinks with it we don't tend to
no we don't know alcohol we don't have
it on occasion on the premises that's
off the premises yeah well exactly so we
certainly do then
um we'll have to wait and see what
happens as far as whether the committee
believe him today it is four
conservatives uh the head of the
committee the chairperson of course is
labor and then we have SMP and lib Dem
as well the only thing I'd say about the
committee and I'm a great fan of
parliamentary committees is I'm very
surprised that when the previous German
stood down because he'd prejudged it
Chris Brighton the right to stand down
the replacement was a former interim
leader of labor party twice interim
leader of labor party had already
prejudiced the matter I thought that I
advised as well well I'm just saying
it's strange isn't it I could have
thought of a lot of Labor MPS who hadn't
prejudged it who could have um been
chairman but that I thought that was
very advised fun are you saying she's
biased uh I I'm not saying I'm just
saying it's unusual okay as long as
you're not saying it's biased because
obviously they would have something to
say about that let me talk quickly about
the vote today Northern Ireland protocol
Boris Johnson says he is going to vote
against it what are you going to do well
we were promised there's one particular
aspect yes that's the point you're
making yeah we were promised a full
debate on the Windsor framework and and
we would have a whole day debate and
then we'd vote on it well we're actually
being asked in 90 minutes is to vote on
one specification break which is then
apparently going to be
um our vote on the whole framework now
if I get a question of pmqs I'm going to
ask the Prime Minister what happened to
our wider vote so I'm really pretty
miffed that they are avoiding the
government's avoiding
um scrutiny on this and uh on the break
itself it seems to
um fail all the tests in fact it's
supposed to be worse than useless so if
that is the case I'm going to listen to
the debate I'm going to go to meetings
this morning
um but my if I had to vote at this
moment of time I should vote against
let's switch and see um let's see if you
get a question a pmq is if you do you'll
be on the Telly because we're covering
it live from noon thank you very much
and thank you for joining as always
thank you
um obviously we'll get uh more on that
it gets pmq's uh live midday here on Sky
News and then that Blockbuster 2 p.m
this afternoon when Boris Johnson has
hours and hours and hours of questioning
about what's happening what happened
behind the front door of dining Street
uh we'll cover that for you live as well
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on Sky News
Wednesday morning if you're queasy about
spiders look away no
previously unknown species of trapdoor
spider has been discovered in Australia
researchers at Queensland Museum
describe it as big and beautiful its
body alone can grow to five centimeters
and they can live as long as 20 years in
Bushland horrible top stories this
morning Boris Johnson is fighting for
his political future as he prepares to
face a grilling by MPS about whether he
knowingly misled party at Parliament
over party gate
rate of inflation has taken a surprise
leap to 10.4 percent driven by record
food costs at 18 percent
Sky News uncovers allegations of
misogyny and bullying at homicide police
with one female serving officer telling
us she's lost face in the fall
cursed armor Under Fire for seeking to
block the government's plans to relax
tax rules on pensions for the wealthy
The Daily Telegraph says the labor
leader is benefiting from a generous
pension arrangement from his time as
director of public prosecutions
it's the lead in the telegraph this
morning what on Earth is going on
tomorrow high so one rule for one that's
what Tory MPS are saying so in the
budget Jeremy Hunt abolished the
lifetime allowance on pensions saying
that would help doctors stay in the
profession there had been a cap of a
million pounds and beyond that you were
taxed a lot on your pension and now the
telegraph are revealing that kirst armor
back when he was director of public
prosecutions had his own pension scheme
which was different to everybody else's
in which there was no cap so he
benefited they say and now he's trying
to restrict that benefit for other
people and it likes Ian Duncan Smith
have said that this is as close to
hypocrisy as it is possible to get now I
understand that when he had that pension
scheme he didn't actually reach the
million pound cap he could have done but
he didn't actually reach it and he's not
paid into it since he stopped doing that
job back in 2013 and of course George
Osborne then raided pensions in the
years after that a labor spokesperson
says of course that the pension scheme
is set by the government of the day it
wasn't set by the director of public
prosecutions himself but I think as this
route escalates of course labor forced
to vote on it yesterday we can we won't
expect to see many conservatives
pointing kirst armor and say well this
is something that you got why shouldn't
other people have it too labor say
they're opposing it because it doesn't
just apply to doctors it also applies to
Bankers as well okay and I think there's
some fun stuff happening at nine o'clock
that we can't talk about at the moment
otherwise you're going to have to kill
us but it's certainly been reflected in
the book Boris Johnson Boris Johnson
indeed so that's lots of coverage on
Boris and partygate in the papers today
they weren't proper Whoppers reads the
Metro on the former PM's defense that he
did mislead MPS but only accidentally
the guardian describes Mr Johnson
fighting for political survival
but the mail is in his Corner saying
bullish Boris up for the fight
away from that the telegraph rights just
hearing that the labor leader sakir
stammer is accused of hypocrisy over a
unique pension deal that's exempt from
tax rules and the times carries a study
which found a slightly increased breast
cancer risk from taking any kind of
hormonal contraception finally the Ft
reporting that a decision on raising the
state pension age 268 has been delayed
partly because of falling life
expectancy
nominations for this year's TV bafta
Awards have just been announced our
entertainment and arts reporter Claire
Gregory is here hi Claire tell me more
yeah so it's a it's an interesting year
the top nominations this year have gone
to this is going to hurt which I don't
know if you remember was the medical
drama it's based on the book by Adam K
so very much kind of written in real
life experiences inspired by those and
then the other top nominated show is the
responder which saw Martin Freeman
playing a police officer also written by
a former police officer so really it
seems like bafta have kind of looked at
things that reflect real life experience
perhaps after the pandemic we weren't
really looking for TV that gave us huge
amounts of escapism and in fact instead
we wanted stuff that reflected our own
realities also doing very well this year
in the nominations is the crown that
often does well at the TV baftas the
English which is a western series
starring Emily Blunt and chasuke Spencer
set in 1890 uh slow horses which is a
good one that's great yeah for horses
I'm glad you uh yeah that was one of my
favorites too yeah and again when was
that wins yeah when we think of slow
horses again it's not the kind of
glamorous James bondweld of spies and
things is it it's kind of the gritty MI5
kind of M25 world of uh well it's about
just I'm sorry if I may it's about MI5
officers who aren't actually very good
anymore or have to be reprogrammed so
they go to the old boy who tries to and
then they then they solve a couple of
crimes that's it and Gary Oldman oh he's
so good and he's up for a for an acting
award for it as well and then um and bad
sisters which is another Apple TV Plus
show um about a kind of group of sisters
who find themselves under investigation
for a life insurance claim when one of
their husbands dies unexpectedly and one
of ours as well with White Lotus White
Lotus I'm afraid didn't make the list I
think it wasn't in the qualifying period
I think that's what went wrong but uh
sky has got some shows in there it's the
BBC are leading the charge this year
they've got almost 50 nominations but
this guy aren't too far behind again the
TV bafters they always tend to sort of
put the terrestrial shows the linear TV
shows they like to kind of lift those up
so we're seeing more nominations for
those than for for sky and for the
streamers well we'll have to change that
way uh when do we know who's won so the
ceremony itself will be hosted by The
Comedians uh Rebecca and Ramesh
ranganathan and that will be in May the
14th of May okay fantastic thanks so
much indeed thank you now Ed Sheeran who
doesn't like a bit of Ed Sheeran says
he's vowed to never touch another
illicit substance after a Corona rule
that the death of Israel Jamal Edwards
was drug related
[Music]
Rolling Stone magazine he also felt he
couldn't go on after the music
entrepreneur's death at 31 just over a
year ago
Edwards helped launch Sheeran's career
so we're going to have uh more uh on
that and also you'll never guess whose
birthday it is today also at musically
related but I'm not going to tell you
any more about that just at the moment
don't forget also we've got Boris
Johnson
um uh he is going to be speaking to the
Privileges committee they've said come
along and have a chat about what was
happening at Downing Street he spent 250
000 pounds of our money legal fees so
far 50-page document was given to the
committee a couple of days ago Monday
evening to be precise and then
um he is now being asked to go and back
up what he said in these documents two
o'clock this afternoon is when Boris
Johnson will be doing that it will be
live on Sky News before that of course
it's pmqs at midday today and in
addition to that there will be a vote on
the Stormont stop for the Northern
Ireland protocol
um or the Westminster the
uh when zero code I think it's called
Windsor framework as it's cool now it's
had so many names where are we on it uh
we'll be talking about that before that
though the Metropolitan Police digesting
baroness case's damning review which
accused the force of institutional
racism sexism and homophobia but there
are sometimes concerns that even
following stinging criticism official
reports don't always lead to change in
Scotland however misogyny is set to
become a crime following a review from
the Barrister and labor peer baroness
Helen a Kennedy who is within us now
baroness Kennedy it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
first of all uh talk to me if you would
please about Louise Casey's report what
did you think
well it really is I mean it's it's
really hot when you're reading it
because it's so excoriating about uh
policing conduct and uh uh you know
Louise Casey is a very very smart woman
she is nobody pulls the wool over her
eyes and uh I just thought that she
pulled no punches she tells it like it
is and the report is really a shocking
read
um we've been hearing things about
um uh policing over many years now
um but somehow uh the the move from
receiving reports into doing something
really substantial about it uh is the
thing that never happens and so the
challenge now is going to be can the
Mage and those are the leaders in
leadership really take hold of this
report and uh and turn the mate around
and that's going to be God's Own
challenge it really is because it's so
embedded this bad behavior this
discrimination this sort of and it comes
out of a sense of being a force and that
you owe loyalty to each other and that
somehow there are these rituals that you
know like urinating on people when they
come in
debasing people and in order somehow to
to create this Primacy of the uh toxic
masculinity that operates within
policing and that has to all be
challenged if we're going to have a
police force that works for everybody
um we've been hearing from the shadow
Home Secretary Yvette Cooper she said
that there should be a national standard
for police vetting procedures I mean you
have looked at the police in up in
Scotland's rules slightly differently
but I'm sure you agree that there should
be vetting procedures how would that
work though
well I mean listen it's that's it's very
tricky to do this sort of thing I mean I
think people should be prepared to
handle over for example their um their
phones I mean we'd have to do it
voluntarily you can't invade people's
privacy without their consent but I
think people who are applying for these
jobs should be willing to let people see
the kind of exchanges that they have on
their WhatsApp and the stuff that they
have on their phones this is you know
this is a way of seeing whether people
are actually misogynistic
um it was only by looking at
um the WhatsApp groups and the policing
that people got to understand just how
deep-rooted
um misogyny and uh and racism and
attitude you know homophobic attitudes
were so deeply embedded in the police
now I I conducted an inquiry in Scotland
which was a different kind of inquiry it
was looking at
um the experiences of women in the
public
um with from other men um it was about
misogyny more generally in society and
how it could be addressed through the
criminal justice system and AI but in
doing that I had received you know the
sort of input from the police and it was
very standard and I got a very
interesting set of um suggestions and so
on on the subject from the police but I
spoke giving
um confidentiality to women police
officers I spoke to women police
officers who told me that inside the
force itself it was a very different
Ballpark and that they themselves
experienced really quite um shocking
levels of misogyny and uh and degrading
um words on a regular basis and so you
know this is not just happening in the
made I think that um it's it's about
something that's in general in our
society as we know
um but it's particularly present in
these
um in these institutions that were all
that used to be completely male and and
therefore a culture has been created
which is very masculine very sexist very
hostile to um and who are not
sufficiently machismo and so there's
there's a horrible exchanges around
homosexuality but of them diminishing
people from minorities but also being
really shocking about women and until
you you know diversify your police force
have it with many more different kinds
of people that you actually start
um disentangling this stuff and
challenging it at every turn and not
punishing the people who challenge it
and unfortunately within the police it's
seen as disloyalty to in any way call
out to the behavior of a colleague and
we would see it regularly obviously I've
been practicing the bar for so many
decades now you would see it when police
officers came to court this business
where you stand together you Britain
allow no breach in your numbers and
therefore you cover up bad behavior and
it led to miscarriages of Justice well
in the past
it's like it leads to um bad behavior
towards minorities and it leads to a
shocking disregard for the complaints
that women make about what's happening
to them because the attitudes of the men
who are doing these terrible things to
women is often shared by police officers
not all but enough to make it a really
alarming uh situation for us as a
society we need to have good policing
and there are many good police officers
and I know them
um but this the challenge to this is uh
is going to be a hard one
Ernest Kennedy it's always good to talk
to you thank you for joining us on the
program thank you before the break I
asked you about the musical Maestro
who's celebrating a birthday today did
you guess who it was he's not afraid of
ghosts it's Andrew Lloyd Webber Baron
Lloyd Webber who turns 75 today he's
famous for Broadway's longest running
show Phantom of the Opera as well as
cats and many many many others his
latest is a musical comedy reimagining
uh Cinderella of course no longer
playing here in the UK but is around the
world
turning now to Donald Trump and the
former president could be indicted by a
grand jury as soon as this week over
alleged hush Money Paid to porn star
Stormy Daniels during his 2016
presidential campaign joined Now by
political activist and lawyer Dr Shola
and also U.S political commentator
Scotty Nell Hughes hello to you both
good to see you this morning we've been
talking about this quite a lot this week
already ladies not least with John
Bolton former Ambassador who says that
he does think he will be indicted
probably sometime this week the
equivalent of arrest I think is that
right Scotty
that's what the rumors are and if you
read Trump's post that he did last week
yesterday it was supposed to be the day
it didn't happen mainly probably because
he was the only one that was putting a
timeline to it but yes there is a grand
jury that is convened but they're basing
this the district attorney of Manhattan
is actually basing this whole case off
of one testimony almost and this is what
you're going with Michael Cohen who's a
lawyer himself has come in and just
poked all sorts of holes into
microphones including giving a personal
Vendetta Michael Cohen has against
Donald Trump showing this is why he's
saying this they cannot believe this man
so once again nine years later ladies or
actually I think we're at what yeah
seven years later we're meeting together
on this morning to talk about Donald
Trump the weather he's indicted or he's
not this is winning to Donald Trump
because we're talking about him and
that's all that he cares about
I know you've got a view on that
I think the culture of impunity must end
this is about accountability and Donald
Trump should be arrested and prosecuted
for any crime that he's committed that's
the bottom line the hush money to Stormy
Daniels is potentially a cover-up for
campaign Finance benefit I.E and on
declared payment on behalf of a
presidential candidate to avoid a public
Scandal now stummy's point about
personal Vendetta that's a talking point
it's not rooted in fact on law it is not
the job of the state prosecutor to look
at the politics surrounding an
individual to determine whether or not
to indict and prosecute them but crime
committed the political position of
Donald Trump as a current presidential
candidate and as a former president only
means the stakes are high and whether or
not you know a trump has you know this
High position in politics or the threat
of his followers protesting his
legitimate arrest is something to become
about I say it's not it cannot be the
litmus test for any civilized law
abiding Society nobody is above the law
is the only standard you must stand by
period
Chola I agree with you nobody's above
the law but that's not the conversation
that we're having here listen to your
own answer first you said a state
attorney this is something that this is
a case that has already been Trump has
been tried in a civil court and One
Stormy Daniels having to pay this is a
case that has already been thrown out by
the federal justice system you had
multiple people I've begged it to take
on this case they said we have nothing
to do with this and you have Michael
Cohen himself the only person that is
saying that campaign finances were used
were Michael Cohen everybody else around
is going not so much now as to this
threat of trump protesters that was
something that Donald Trump called for
he called for it on Tuesday
there was maybe a handful people there I
think the American people I think even
his supporters recognize that right now
that rallying to a city like New York is
not a friendly place to those in the
Trump base so therefore they stayed home
so that threat is non-existent whether
Trump takes that as a compliment or not
well I I'm listening to you start I'm
listening to you Scott Scotty and I I
and I wonder if you're listening to what
you're saying fine there was a simple
case but that's not what we're talking
about here as long as it is as long as
the prosecutor has a case that's
supported by law and the fact that is
the issue and the bottom line here is it
doesn't matter how long it took that is
not an argument not to prosecute
somebody other people get prosecuted
even though it takes forever and a half
point to happen or it took two months
for the prosecutors to put their case
together the bottom line is as long as
it's supported by law and the fact and
your point about Michael Cohen well let
the god of law determine whether his
evidence his testimony is strong enough
to prosecute
um Donald Trump that is what the court
says like I'm not gonna have to stop you
there because we are out of time busy
program this out but I want you come
back and continue that conversation stay
tuned
thank you